*Titelmelodie*
Die Truppe, die ihr vor kurzem in
unserem Grill Video bewundert habt,
hat mich gefragt, wie eigentlich
Sonnenschutz genau funktioniert.
Und ich hoffe sehr,
dass das Wetter angemessen ist,
wenn dieses Video online geht.
Sonnenlicht ist nicht nur schön,
sondern überlebenswichtig.
Aber zu viel UV-Strahlung
führt nicht nur zu Sonnenbrand
und zu schnellerer Hautalterung,
sondern ist auch die einzig
nachgewiesene Ursache
für Hautkrebs.
Oder zumindest die einzige Ursache,
die wir beeinflussen können.
Neben Sonnenhut oder
einfach mal drinnen bleiben,
schützt Sonnencreme
vor UV-Strahlung.
Und zwar so:
Eine Möglichkeit
ist physikalischer Schutz.
Durch mineralische Nanopartikel,
die das UV-Licht reflektieren.
Am meisten verwendet werden
Nanopartikel aus Titandioxid,
ein weißes Farbpigment, das u.a.
in Wandfarbe, Zahnpasta
und Kaugummis zu finden ist.
Oder Zinkoxid, ein anderes
Weißpigment, das auch in Malerfarbe
aber u.a. auch als Beschichtung
von Fotopapier zum Einsatz kommt.
Zweite Möglichkeit
ist ein chemischer Sonnenschutz,
durch sogenannte
aromatische Moleküle.
Aromatisch nennt man Moleküle, wenn
sie so einen oder mehrere Ringe
in ihrer Struktur haben.
Diese Moleküle
können durch ihre aromatischen Ringe
UV-Licht absorbieren.
Sie nehmen es auf
und wandeln es in Wärme um.
Sowohl zu den Nanopartikeln als
auch zu den organischen Substanzen
gibt es Diskussionen
zu Gesundheit und Umwelt,
die aber bisher strittig bleiben.
Meine persönliche Einschätzung zur
aktuellen wissenschaftlichen Lage
ist, schmiert euch lieber gut ein.
Denn Hautkrebs is coming for you.
Um sich richtig einzucremen,
sollte man erstmal
den Lichtschutzfaktor
richtig verstehen.
Dazu kann man sich klarmachen,
wie dieser im Labor bestimmt wird.
Hierzu werden Menschen,
also Probanden,
mit einer künstlichen
Sonnenlichtquelle bestrahlt,
bis sich die Haut rötet.
Der Mediziner sagt:
"bis sich ein Erythem bildet".
Und das macht man einmal mit
und einmal ohne Sonnencreme.
Der Lichtschutzfaktor
ergibt sich jetzt folgendermaßen.
Er ist die Zeit, bis die Rötung
auftritt mit Sonnencreme
geteilt durch die Zeit, bis die
Rötung auftritt ohne Sonnencreme.
Lichtschutzfaktor 15 bedeutet also,
dass ich genau 15 mal länger
in der Sonne bleiben kann
als ohne Sonnencreme.
Und mit "genau"
meine ich "ungefähr".
Man unterscheidet zwischen
sechs verschiedenen Hauttypen,
wo bei die Übergänge
sicher fließend sind.
Jedenfalls
allein die Eigenschutzzeit
der verschiedenen Hauttypen
kann sehr stark variieren.
Von 10 Minuten...
Alle Rothaarigen say hey!
Bis hin zu 90 Minuten...
Der Lichtschutzfaktor,
der auf der Flasche steht,
das ist nur ein Durchschnittswert.
Außerdem sollte man auch
bei hohen Lichtschutzfaktoren
vorsichtig sein.
Ab einem Lichtschutzfaktor
von 30 und aufwärts
kann man diese Messungen im Labor
nicht mehr so genau durchführen.
Weil die Bestrahlungszeiten
einfach zu lang wären.
Darüber hinaus cremen wir uns
anscheinend nicht dick genug ein.
Sag ich doch!
Laut dem Deutschen Institut für
Normung bezieht sich die Wirksamkeit
von Lichtschutzfaktoren auf
eine Sonnencremedicke von 1,5 mg
pro Quadratzentimeter.
In der Praxis,
das hat man untersucht,
cremen wir uns nur mit etwa 0,5 mg
pro Quadratzentimeter Haut ein.
Also, was lernen wir daraus?
Cremt euch oft genug ein!
Empfohlen ist so jede halbe Stunde.
Verlasst euch nicht
auf zu hohe Lichtschutzfaktoren!
Und cremt euch dick genug ein.
Schönschlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text, 2017
im Auftrag von Funk
Damit hoffe ich für euch
und für mich, dass heute,
wenn das Video rauskommt,
ein schöner sonniger Tag ist,
den wir sowohl genießen können
als auch die Tipps anwenden können.
Auch wenn ein sonniger Tag heißt,
dass die Viewerzahlen auf Youtube
meistens nicht so gut sind;
zu Recht.
Aber, um das zu kompensieren,
könnt ihr das Video ja teilen.
Oder kommentieren.
Oder abonnieren.
Ha Schätzeleins,
ihr wisst doch Bescheid.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bleibt sicher.